boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Saucon and
we are again sitting down with our
e-news M re what else for coming on for
a second straight episode how badass you
for join us for two straight episodes
that was episode three four five we
talked with Ari about his life and about
fulfillment and sustainability in
finding lots of meaning in life and
building out systems that facilitate
that to really solid episode go check it
out everyone
now after immediately after the episode
Ari is like let's talk when I ask you
some questions so now our he's gonna ask
me some questions
I personally was like just drooling with
how smart Ari is as a 19 year old like
if we had more of people that are young
and smart like you building the funk
sure yeah that's that's how I feel and
and we're gonna build that future that
fosters more of this of this some like
just you know adolescent just brilliance
and that's gonna really push us forward
so Ari
jump us in to your questions let's do
awesome okay so you've talked a little
bit about how you really like thinking
about how to update civilizations code
can you just give us a preliminary like
definition of what you mean by that or
what what you mean by code how you would
define that and how you define
civilization and I'm kind of that
process okay all right so let's it's
great that's a great place to start we
are very obsessed with thinking about
things like the current code of
civilization and you know and how to
update that to maximize flourishing
let's call that the objective now that
is already a very complicated thing that
was just said so let's break it down
with the first part which is
civilization and code okay so I think
probably one of the easiest let's say
algorithms or loops to understand and
encode is that your heart beats a
hundred thousand times a day
sure okay so we can start with something
quite simple and easy like that
we can then do things like say that the
earth is 93 million miles from the star
okay
so that's another very a mathematical
way of seeing from the biological just
right here is just level all the way to
the star system level okay so that's
what we mean by civilizations code
things like that then there's obviously
even more complex code like eight
billion of these human animals and how
they interact with each other in
economies and social fabrics and
political spheres which add a ton of
different complex code that actually
makes that happen but you can kind of
potentially even think of something like
when you
when you when you when you see that 90%
of all world trade currently happens of
across seas and then you think about how
a good gets manufactured resources are
made for that good that goods
manufactured that good is shipped
somewhere that good is then sold
somewhere and that good is then consumed
etc you can kind of follow a like a
codified process of it going from a
specific place being shipped across
consumed in another location there being
a financial transaction for that entire
process okay so yes ago I would say so
the kind of your heart beats a hundred
thousand beats per second and the
hundred thousand times a day 100
thousand times a day yes 100 thousand
times a day yes and the earth being a
certain distance from the Sun yes you
would consider that in the same code as
like political entities and as like
culture yeah this is a very good
question so let's let's take it a by a
let's let's yeah sure let's let's break
it down into into into everything falls
into the code okay
okay every so your difference or the
code everything is in everything all
that is is within the code vente okay
all that is is within the code but then
the code can be broken down in these
sections which we can observe here with
heartbeat is a very you know biological
thing the distance to the star is a very
like a static e thing well yeah exactly
it's 93 million ish almost all the time
right right so
so by civilisations code yeah that's the
complex so you're not talking about you
know changing the distance between the
Sun and the moon it's like that what
you're talking about is the the cultural
code that we're running in yes so now
that is the more difficult code right
because I think that to talk about how
eight billion human animals interact
with each other and augmenting the code
let's let's take an example the we
talked about this in the last episode
that we did how the the transition to
too firm for our species to to
agriculture and what that did right
agriculture was a massive change in code
right okay absolutely that's how that's
kind of like oh maybe a way to you know
to think about things is like okay the
domestication the then the the
domestication of other of other animals
of land over and over again for those
soil systems but then also us being less
of wandering us wandering less us
building out you know the communities
outward but agriculture is only you know
one of so so many right um you know
language and the wheel changed code fire
changed the code but then that goes all
the way up to you know to to automobiles
antibiotics commercial airplanes
photography Internet personal computers
all those things also did massive
changes in code done and then one of the
things that I think is very important to
address is I believe we can objectively
decide as a civilization which
advancements in code were what
percentages of those advancements were
malevolent and which ones were
benevolent hmm so let's take that that's
an interesting yeah that's an
interesting idea because it's hard to
know you know it's hard to know when
it's created what the effects benevolent
or malevolent may be right because what
we were talking about in the last
episode was social media and smartphones
and kind of how these technologies are
influencing the youth and if you think
about it when it was created I think a
lot of people say you know we're
uniting the globe I think when people
were going about making the internet
they said you know we're connecting the
world that's going to be unlimited
access to knowledge and all this stuff
and what you've seen is that is true but
where's most of the Internet traffic
actually going right and what percentage
of that is actually to access all this
like knowledge and this academic stuff
and how much of it is to clickbait and
how much of it is to like Isis or
terrorist groups that are using it as a
platform to amplify themselves or or
other things like that so I think there
you go I think you know maybe from if
you were out like a God's eye standpoint
maybe you could kind of see them and
never lay below the thing yeah I think
it's something that's constantly in flux
and it's changing based on how people
are using it and kind of the direction
that's being taken but but it's a really
interesting concept to think about so
now take exactly what you're just saying
take yourself okay you're in all that is
okay you are looking at the code of all
that is and you are taking this God's
eye or this you know ten thousand foot
whatever perspective on civilization ten
thousand mile however whatever view you
want to take on civilization you're in
the middle of all that is of the code
and you're watching a coded deployment
be dropped into civilization and yes at
first it is like agriculture is gonna be
absolutely fantastic social media is
gonna be absolutely fantastic right so
then you can begin to Eric Weinstein
interestingly enough air going sign shut
up
angle of declination hmm so you can
actually start objectively measuring how
the code deployment is doing in terms of
what its initial purpose was to do
and then if the angle of declination
becomes even lower than than zero you
know it's a cute angle has went downward
well instead of upward you know mission
its mission and values are you know
let's say at an angle of ten ten degrees
you know it's like great it's like
positive code deployments and then you
get some of these code deployments that
angled downward angle declination went
downward not inclination but declination
right and so then the ideas how do you
have and this is what Pia and I were
talking about early life was what we
were talking about how do you
objectively in a consensus mechanism
make decisions amongst eight billion
human animals about the angle of
declination about the code deployment
how well is the code deployment doing
it's such a tricky question right
because I think you said the initial
angle is the purpose at the beginning
but you know a lot of a lot of these
innovations and stuff like that their
purpose is actually not what they get
and you know what they end up getting
used for at all and it's it's a tricky
thing because are you are you you know
looking at it and saying how is this
compared to its original purpose are you
comparing it to its original purpose are
you comparing it to the overall good
it's had on humanity and it's hard to
say those things because I think you
know that's dynamically moving great
it's like it's like moving and it's and
I think it's hard to say for whom to
write because something that's been
really amazing for you know a couple
people in Silicon Valley which is you
know all this explosion of wealth and
technology has been very detrimental to
people in other parts of the world right
and actually probably more people right
if you think about you know where the
medal in our laptops are coming from or
where the paper that we're now printing
on are able to print on because we're
creating so much more media is now
getting we have this huge demand for
paper right or this huge demand for
microfiber cloths or this huge demand
for all these random things that we
didn't care about before are now there's
this huge demand for those things right
Jun in the event was talking about
Foxconn right these these factories that
are producing the iPhones in our pockets
and where these people are deep then how
me and really having a hard time and so
there are some aspects to the code
deployment right here's the nuance right
you have to be able to abstractly reason
with dozens if not hundreds of different
variables at the same time and this is
where things get complex because we are
too addicted to cognitive ease we're too
addicted to tribalism and echo chambers
and filter bubbles and that becomes a
massive problem because then you lose
the nuance you lose being able to
measure that dozens to hundreds of
referent variables and so when when you
have someone saying that Apple is bad or
Apple is good right right you're missing
you're missing all the nuance because
they are providing us at these
incredible technological races at the
same time as causing some ecological
issues as well as mental health issues
in the rain you factoring process and
some things we don't even know for
hundreds of years to come right like the
reason why we're together right now is
because I got an email to come to this
other event and if I had never had a
phone or a communication method to get
that you know maybe we wouldn't be
sitting down here and then what would
our lives look like so it's so hard to
keep track of all these different
timelines going on in these different
ways and I think something you said was
interesting because I want to I want to
investigate something you said when you
said you know these code these coach
angel these codes at the code editions
and I think the way maybe I've been
thinking about it is that the universe
or or the world kind of had like a
github repo if you will that was like
kind of static right oh I'm already like
the humans before not even humans I
guess our ancestors before we started
you know showing traits that were like
very exceptional so maybe like
Australopithecus and something that when
we're really living off the land when
we're really kind of as you've all Hari
would call a like an animal of no
significance right when we're basically
just part of the circle of life living
by our own unique methods but not
aberrant from the norm like we are now
in that period I think you know the code
is kind of running the way that it was
always running right it's running on
biological processes it's running at a
speed of biology it's running at the
speed of evolution and it's kind of when
you know Homo sapiens started or I mean
let's go back even a little further
right it's right it's right when erectus
started using fire and a little bit
further it's when Homo sapiens started
developing language in the cognitive
revolution and then tools that that
those are I think are the first code
additions right I mean maybe you could
push back on this and because you can
also go all the way back to the initial
birth of life on the on that right and
you could say that's a code addition you
could also go back to Big Bang so that's
the starting point right code so maybe
maybe then the the idea is not that
humans have invented the code addition
but maybe then the idea is that humans
are accelerating the rate at which code
is deployed because before you know we
were talking the speed of biology the
speed of evolution is much slower the
deployment of that code takes you know
death and life to actually either keep a
part of the code or remove it from the
code base right we're making the system
more entropic then we're adding entropy
to the system by adding code wouldn't we
be because yeah it says us creating like
language at its is adding code that's
never been there before
okay that's order and disorder doesn't
it both so then that becomes a hard
thing that's okay okay but okay so
you're doing something that's really
great right now which is you're you know
you're taking us to thinking about the
whole thing from the Big Bang till now
as as code and then then you took us to
you know the first edition of a you know
language and fire being code deployment
written all the way to social media
being coded great right now what we want
to do right let's get to this to the
crux of the variables right to the to
the nuance within it right we can pretty
much almost completely argue that that
fire is like a vast majority excellent
code
appointment potentially for who well us
well okay okay fine let's find a
different ones right if what is language
of 100% not we we can't be a hundred
right everything's on a probability
curve so it's language at least you know
97% positive on a code deployment and
then maybe only 3% of it needs to be
like augmented some right for the
neologism the new words that I think for
I think for any of for assessing the
malevolence or benevolence of any of
these code deployments we have to say
for who I think I think I think we can I
agree with you that we can say this was
good or bad but I think we have to say
for who we can't do overall press it
well you can't do that or you can do it
for for the human civilization but I
don't think you can do it for like the
universe or for all life okay well
because if you say fire because you say
fire it harms even thing because it
makes us the apex predator because then
we but it brings us burnt trees right
which is not great for them but it's
good for us grief and language makes it
cooked animals cooked animals but it
makes it easy for us to communicate with
each other language which means we can
team up better and beat other animals
better so it's much better for us but
it's at the cost of her something else
this is very fair so I would agree with
you that looking at it from the human
lens that it's that we can assess the
okay yeah I have one what about the
human
fully realizing their divine communion
with evolution with all that is so I
would be probably a net positive yeah
net positive for everything there we go
there's one that's an interest that
that's yeah okay do you think do you
think that we had that before the advent
of Agriculture this with Emin ism yeah
this is a very interesting question
because you know when you think about
things on as a knowledge graph and you
think about the the edge of knowledge I
do think it's potential that the edge of
knowledge for like spiritual connection
to the universe and all that is
potentially was further out in our past
than it is now really that it's
contracted potentially the spiritual
connection to to the you know has
receded has versi out completely great
potentially yeah I would definitely drew
yeah it's that that might be an
unfortunate one and so so then you know
one of the things okay fine we just
identified it like one of the ones that
we think is potentially completely not
completely in a postcode system
yeah it's is humans so that so now this
takes us to you know one of the along
with thinking of everything as code and
let's think of humans as seeds okay
okay so human is birthed into the world
the moment that they are birthed into
the world and of course there's also
things to say about when they're
actually in in in developing inside of
the woman just stating right right but
but let's say from the moment of birth
as the seed the seed needs the right
nutrients yes and now this becomes the
question is what is the code to deploy
to the nutrients as the birth into the
world well one of the things we can
probably say for sure which we hinted at
earlier is that it's a net positive for
the seed to understand that it is
connected to very spiritually to all
that is absolutely okay so there's that
net positive
another net positive is that it gets
love and compassion probably from I
think that it's probably a net positive
for every think is if that like could
there be ever a positive where this yeah
I think I think well I think it needs
water
I think they need food right those are
yeah I think the net positive that we
can identify is the connection to
everything else because that keeps it
within the the ecosystem yes and makes
it so that it's respectful of the
ecosystem and thus like isn't that
positive for everything in the ecosystem
I think anything kind of besides that is
still valuable for us because we are the
humans but we can't necessarily say is a
net positive for the rest of the world
and I think that's fine right I think
it's fine to say you know having
mentorship and having education and
having access to technology whatever is
good for a human growing up but I think
you know making the claim that well it's
good for the universe as a whole is a
harder claim yeah it is a harder claim
but can we at least make air right so
access to oxygen to breathe right to
clean air
yeah I mean if that human is providing
back into the overall system if that
human is destroying the overall
ecosystem Anna Campion ab+ correct from
so then so then okay yeah so this is the
code this is where we're starting to get
yeah more into complexity so let's so
then we would have to say like okay
let's say that the the the consumption
of the seed is let's say does not cause
harm like you can't can you really say
that eating you know like spinach is
causing spinach harm and as a net you
know negative to the spinach and then
you know because then then that throws
okay we might have to not go into
hundred percents this is where we may
never circle you to 90 90 tens or not go
into the nets because I think if we stay
within the human purview we can we can
make progress but okay and when you when
you go into like eat spinach I heard
spinach that yeah when you
you get into that stuff I think I mean
it's it's an interesting like
philosophical debate does it have
realistic implications for our lives
less so maybe if we really thought about
it and really comes down to it also
humans could make way more spinach if we
were really actualized to our fullest
and using and then the spinach could
have more of its ability to to be its
conscious spinach so like maybe maybe
like the the final thing we can say
about the the net stuff is like for the
worm right like we can say it's good for
the worm to eat the soil right to the
the decomposing material because then it
produces soil that then is makes fertile
things for other things but it's a very
complex sorry simple system right it's
almost an input and an output you have
kind of biomass going in and and fertile
biomass coming out there's like there's
a good thing happening there and in that
process you know the worm has a
livelihood in the worm has a life the
the tricky stuff is I think when you get
to humans when we no longer a part of
the biological yes circle and so when we
eat spinach you know our waste doesn't
necessarily go fertilize something it
gets like shot out into the ocean it's
not necessarily going back into the
ecosystem so I think it's harder to say
for humans also because you know
mentorship may be incredibly incredibly
powerful for a human but does it have an
impact on the palm tree down down the
street probably not right and so unless
it's a paper company or something like
that right in which it could and maybe
that's like a really interesting kind of
hole to go down yeah I think if we're
gonna talk about how to nurture the
human seed how to nurture the the human
yes it's a somewhat of a different
conversation because it it's more about
these exist C's convent it's it is it's
an ascension but it's yeah it's
selecting a different area okay so let's
okay so let's um
so now let's let's take it from
seeing all it is as code and seeing a
the angle of you know inclination or
declination as something that can that's
impacting all that is code let's maybe
think about it as how it impacts the
civilizations code so strictly the civil
so strictly humans yeah and this was
what makes it hard because there is no
other right there are these lines are
completely arbitrary right sense and so
this is what makes it potentially a
little difficult but located start there
so okay even though you have to consume
you know you get you're getting love the
seed is birth it's getting love and
compassion it's getting full spiritual
connection to to all that is it's
getting of food it's getting water so
you know so love compassion food water
all that is you know and then from there
air right airs and other ones so these
are these are kind of these basic this
is like maslov's hierarchy eats right
yeah so so you can break the stuff down
I think it's a multiple categories so
what we were talking about in the
previous episode is some of the stuff I
think would make a really great
community and that's taken for granted
kind of the stuff that we're just
talking about now which is the basic
needs right so to have a person grower
or to have a fulfilling life I think the
first step is the basic needs right and
that's something we kind of jumped over
in the last episode when we went
straight to okay you have the basic
needs met what's going on then but I
think the first step is is to meet the
basic needs yes and so many seeds are
going without the basic needs met
exactly okay so this is kind of one of
the thesis ha's of the code right
we have civilizations code here in front
of us and we can call it the code of all
that is and now we're honing in on
civilizations code one of the greatest
malevolence is that is occurring in
civilizations code is the lack of
nutrients to the seeds and a second
basic need
yeah yeah and then and then so that is
causing significant trauma that's
causing significant ignorance lack of
potential right yeah the potential that
is not being actualized because we can
even see you know the human has the
ability to grow to six feet right always
did we we didn't change anything
it's the nutrients that we've been
having that allows us today to be much
taller than our ancestors it's not
because you know anything else it's
really that we were you know you could
call us malnourished then and now we're
getting so many more nutrients so many I
mean there are people who make arguments
that we were getting more nutrients when
we were hunter-gatherers because we had
more diverse diets I think we probably
had better micro biomes and things like
that from like a mass of food we have
been able to intake though which is
stuff I think the stuff that affects
height more I think microbiome is more
like health like like gut health but on
like for a height level for like a
muscle mass building level we've been
able to just ingest so much more meat
than our ancestors have ever been to you
know able to ingest and that's why we're
so much bigger and so like this and I
think that's an analogy for what's
happening around the world today where
you know you're gonna have a guest on me
I think tomorrow right
who is mentioning how different
populations can have different average
IQs which is kind of a risky area to get
into but the reasons people have kind of
put together for that is that certain
people are getting access to different
nutrients when they're really young and
that can affect brain development and
lack of access to nutrients can actually
hinder brain development in the long
term right so if those those human seeds
if you will aren't getting access to you
know the basic basic needs the the food
water or the correct amount of stuff
like that you know you're gonna have
these these at the root core you're
gonna have these big structural problems
in that in that person flourishing right
now that that's it that's it we are
right in the thesis of my recent life
ya know right now this is
the most recent thesis of my life is
trying to figure out how to deploy code
most effectively with the resources that
we have to make sure that the seeds are
getting the right nutrients around
distributed right and just because it's
not like we don't have it's like it's
not like we don't know how to do this
right and it's and it's also not that we
don't have enough food it's also not
that we don't have enough water it's
that they're being hoarded right 50% of
the food and the us is wasted and 40% of
it is in the production phase right only
10% of it is like when it's on shelves
in stuff like that I mean a ton of this
stuff is just getting wasted in the
production phase so it's not an issue at
all actually talks but the book issue
actually talks a good amount about this
is that you know all those farms in the
middle of the u.s. those aren't just
feeding Americans those are feeding the
huge populations in other parts of the
globe too and they're they're getting no
guarantee that those populations are
gonna stop producing so they're there's
new people being born they need food
right or else they'll die so the food is
produced in like you know more developer
to the world and then sent over there so
then it grows and then the food
production has to ramp up so it grows
and there's no there's no balancing on
it and this is because of the
Agricultural Revolution right before the
Agricultural Revolution the amount of
food in the environment bounds the
population growth right the number of
bison the number of berries on the trees
the number of grains available to eat
and harvest or not harvest but to gather
bounds the population so the population
can't get out of hand what happens is
that when we started domesticating
agriculture is that we were able to have
these huge population explosions which
then put more stress on the environment
and you know are are cost some of the
hiccups in the code when certain seeds
didn't get the right nutrients that they
exactly if you were me if we were making
sure that every single seed when they're
birthed into the world when we only had
a hundred thousand people on the planet
was getting the right nutrients and
there were no malevolence is that there
was in no time that that the child from
especially from from zero to six months
was having trauma lack of love and
compassion lack of water lack of food
lack of air it said we would we would
have we would have a much if that
happened at every stage for every seed
up until now we would have we would our
code would be really strong our played
in a different place Oh robust yeah I
would be flying through the air
but our plane is made of you know weak
material yeah because what what so so
the plain metaphor that we're using just
to give back on it what it would it
basically the idea behind that is that
there is a law of life as it were just
like there is a law of thermodynamics or
a law of aerodynamics and so here we're
using the law of aerodynamics example so
the idea being that when you create a
paper airplane I mean we can even do it
as an example when you create a paper
airplane that doesn't obey the law of
aerodynamics it's not like that airplane
explodes in your hand great it's not
that you throw that airplane and God
comes down and swats it it's that you
throw that airplane and it just doesn't
fly very far or very well or it crashes
or it skews or it does weird stuff and
the the idea is that you create a paper
airplane or a real airplane that is
obeying the correct laws of aerodynamics
and it actually will fly and it will do
what it's meant to do but there this
isn't like a video game you know where
you make a wrong step and it beeps this
is this is the real real world and so
you disobey the law of physics your
shuttle explodes you know someone
doesn't come down and tell you hey pal
you messed it up right and so the idea
behind the book Ishmael is that the
moment that we decided to disobey the
law of life which is what he in the book
says is when we started the Agricultural
Revolution when we said we are going to
make our own food source he says that is
a disobeying of the law of life that no
other animal does
that and that's why they're able to
survive and very interesting with that
when you disobey it and make your own
food supply then you dominate the
ecosystem because you're you need more
food to sustain your population so you
need the food that you need and not the
food that you know the bees need or the
food that the other animals need and so
you end up dominating the world and
creating a monoculture which ultimately
leads to your to your own destruction
also it almost seems as though that then
that is when it becomes the Anthropocene
that's the moment when humans say that
we're taking over the coup we're taking
control we now have the race and then
all the way from that until Rockets you
know blasting off right so let's let's
come to this really I think I think we
can probably play on this for
we we give this really solid
illustration of what it'd be like let's
say if you know we're at the hundred
thousand people and every single time
that a new seed is born that there's no
no nutrient loss every single time that
every single time the seed is getting
everything it needs to flower at its
fullest as your itis that's a very
beautiful thing for that human to be at
their fullest right and we see a major
lack of that in terms of especially the
spiritual connection one that one
specifically is a major lack that's why
there's so many a lot of a lot of issues
we have now let's talk about the how to
deploy currently because that is like if
you press the reset button right now and
pressing the reset Bunz a great you know
you were to you or you were pointing at
this earlier you know the show is called
simulation well it's called simulation
for a myriad of reasons one of them
being it's fascinating to think about
and run simulations in your mind what
would have earth look like if every
scene guy at the water that any bravery
mind so that we can't unfortunately go
back to that point until we run our own
simulation and watch how it would have
evolved because right on a flourishing
scale we can totally see that it would
have went like this the airplane right
the airplane how robust would have their
plane been built the paper airplane
whereas ours is much more yeah this over
time and and I just wanna exactly I want
to talk about the actual code
deployments in the current right yes
this is what you know eight billion of
us human animals you know exponential
technology and a lack in many ways of
that connection to all that is that
really spiritual communion that isn't
that is missing in many ways so now how
do you run a code deployment on to
civilization that you know we already
gave this interesting example earlier
that a code deployment of spiritual
communion is potentially Net+ purple
that is right
okay so then potentially it is a good
code deployment would be how can you
deploy code that actualizes people
spiritually in a very effective way yeah
because meditation seems to be a very
interesting one psychic Daleks seems to
be a very interesting one so the so I
think the the the the analogy with the
with the paper airplane is that you know
we're going we're going on a path
currently that is actually falling like
we're almost actually hitting the ground
we just don't notice it and people look
at you know the graphs of technological
progress and all the stuff and say oh
we're doing great but what they don't
realize is that that's just the plane
flying badly and it just it just hasn't
hit yet and that we're actually not
flying on a direct course I think the
reason we're not flying on a dark horse
is what you're saying what is the lack
of connection to everything because I
think if we were genuinely connected we
wouldn't be doing a lot of the things
that we're doing right now that's making
the the plane fly badly because we if we
understood we were part of the circle of
life if we understood that we were one
species and that we're one you know
we're connected to the earth we wouldn't
be doing a lot of the things that we
think are the right thing to do and so
what's that what it's doing is I think
we have two problems in right now you
have the people who don't have their
basic needs met yet are suffering right
and then you have the people whose basic
needs are met and the system isn't great
for them either
right you have you know you and me and
the people living in our society aren't
actually doing that well either right we
were talking about the metrics earlier
we were talking about the rates of
depression and suicide and anxiety and
loneliness loneliness is such a such a
real thing and it's happening right and
just a constant overwhelming pressure to
climb up the hierarchy of money and a
Fame and of power and of influence
comfort and in how the birthright and
become a better mate right just a
constant barrage right yeah and it's and
so no one's happy right it's not it's
not it's not that people who don't have
their basic needs met you know a lot of
people say oh you know the noble savage
thing no no like they're there but if
your basic needs are met you're not
you're not doing great and there's no
way to romanticize that right and I
think we shouldn't also romanticize
people who do other basic needs met and
say well well why are you sad you know
it's because if these other things that
play it's not about the basic needs so
that might be the some of the bad code
then yeah so I and it's the thing that's
causing both of these right the same
thing that's driving these people to
chase wealth and status and stuff is the
same thing that's making it so that
those other people don't have their
basic needs met because it's taking all
those Reese's these people are saying we
need more right we need more more more
more more more MORE and these people are
saying we just need the basic stuff what
happens is then you get there maybe this
in terms you're taking resources away
from the people who don't have their
basic needs met and giving extra stuff
to the people who've already have their
basic needs met and the problem is is
that those people aren't getting happier
with the new things that they're getting
new things and the people obviously
don't have their businesses and hobby so
what do you do about it
so what's the code update what's the
code update I think we started touching
on this last time I think the code
update is is this new model of living
and I think it's a model of living that
everyone has to be on board with and
they can do in their own way they can
wear whatever t-shirt whatever color
whatever you know they want to wear
there's pretty much the you know the
closest one like interdependent
capitalism so pretty pretty close it's
ok I think I think I mean I think I
think so too I need a really know me to
cover to cover covered over straight
yeah but I think it's a it's talking
about it probably has already said all
the stuff that we're saying ya know it
but the new the new new code deployment
of inclusive fitness right inclusive
stake holding and of a global village
the capable of spending to the global
village so you that you get an incentive
for helping others others yeah because
you realize that the things that are
gonna make your life great aren't
actually
those resources that you're taking from
other people you realize that the thing
that's actually going to make you happy
and gonna make those people happy is
having your basic needs man number one
and then number two having autonomy
having purpose having mastery having a
sense of belonging and having gratitude
and that is what gives meaning to your
life after you have your basic needs met
and we can have everyone in the world
have that because that doesn't require a
huge you know inequality of resource
distribution right resources can be
basically basic needs I mean in some
places people are gonna get you know
probably a little bit more and some
people people are gonna get a little bit
less but hopefully if we can hit the
basic needs and then try to give people
the autonomy the the purpose the mastery
and and how we do that is through these
communities I think okay alright 150
yeah you're in what you described in the
in the previous episode that is your
current code deployment that you're
deploying yourself let's let's not let's
explore the the idea of
what what would what is it is it a is it
a it's a you know we we we do think of
options I mean I listed these options
when we were all gathering this last
weekend but there are so many options
some people say that for the for the
resources to be allocated for the basic
needs to be met of the vast majority and
then in order for that to then I kind of
I think I found like a pretty easy way
to explain it's just that like this is
the top of the resource consumption and
ownership and asset said all that wealth
etc and this is the bottom right right
the idea is just to bring the baseline
up like this right and and like focus on
that right and then they both move up
together versus you know which in many
ways what it seems like is this is just
rising up and Rises like going up and
it's like great it's coming up yeah and
yeah and that's not actualizing people
as and I think what we actually need is
even instead of instead of just even the
bottom catching up to where we're at
which is what's happening slowly now if
you look at China if you look at India
they're trying to industrialize they're
trying to do the things that we did we
actually don't need to be this high I
think that's the point here is that we
have too much right now but thank you
that we actually have a lot that we
don't need right now and so so there's
actually a really destructive thing
that's happening in the world right now
which is other countries trying to
emulate the American model which is huge
over consumption right don't we use 25%
of the world's resources do and we have
five percent of the popular a five
percent of population if every country
did that I mean you don't need to be
like Stephen Hawking to figure out that
that's an equation that doesn't work I
think what do you do here at the top
then to say that oh well you know you
don't you know how do you get that you
don't need five yachts five cars five
houses six gold watches etc how do you
get
how do you solve that that that seems
like a very challenge yeah it's it seems
challenging June I forget the Nate I was
forget the name or the closet but I know
what the concept is the idea of the the
bell curve of how ideas and our
technologies get propagated into society
so there there are the medics and the
early adopter early adopters yeah you
know you have the early majority the
late majority the laggards and it's
basically a really small percentage of
people at the edge who are coming up
with the new technologies the new
innovations and then those are kind of
adopted by the rest of the curve over
time yes and so what I think you need to
do is you need to prove in an edge case
you need to prove that yes you actually
don't need all that stuff to live a
fulfilling life because I don't think
anyone's proven it relevantly and proven
it in a way that resonates with people
yet in the 70s they tried to prove it
right they tried to say you don't need
this stuff but I think it was too out
there
it was too isolated it was too
counterculture that everyman you know
the the middle of the people I wish I
had that graphic of it but the the
majority of people are in the middle of
the bell curve they're not you know
willing to commit people so I don't want
to experiment in oh if I get the second
house then I'll be out if I get the
second car then I'll be happy now it's a
more approving it now it seems more
objectively true to people that no no no
that won't make me happy in that right
so then the code deployment seems to
potentially work with higher efficacy
now but then you need like you were
pointing at the early adopters on this
side to pick up on that code deployment
right teach other people that you know
we have the giving pledge right now at
least you know that's happening that you
know that it needs to become popular to
say that hey I have you know forty
thousand dollars and instead of buying a
Tesla right I'm gonna give a thousand
dollars to 40 different artists and
entrepreneurs right and that needs to
become popular yeah and and you look at
the phone you know a lot of the phone
comes out a lot of people say oh I need
a phone
I have my blackberry or whatever and
then everyone suddenly you know after a
couple years that the tipping what kinda
happens I think it's between like 13 and
18 percent of market penetration and
then you get the the early majority
which is the front half of the bell
curve the front half of the majority of
the bell curve that tips and then adopts
the new thing and so what I think we
need to do is literally you and me the
the Pantheon the community we're
building needs to prove this new model
needs to say hey you can actually have a
good life living in a community without
all this extra stuff and have it be
actually real to people show them that
we're actually living a good life and
we're not you know running around in the
forest in loincloths we're living
legitimate proper lives that you know
you could actually have and you could
still be working jobs and still be
contributing to to the economy or
contributing in ways that you find
meaningful but you actually don't need
all that other stuff because you're
satisfied in these other ways I think
once we prove that once we as the early
adopt as the very edge case prove it and
it slowly starts to propagate and you
know more knowing that people and can
imagine leaving college Wow and joining
a community it's so funny that our full
circle is that the code deployment that
we are seeking is the panthéon yeah
that's what I think I mean of course I'm
biased because I think a lot about it
but I think you know that is the way is
that you you prove it in an edge case
just like how you know a couple people
got the first iPhone are like hey this
is really useful and then more and more
people got it and there got to a point
where everyone was like yeah if I could
have one I want to have one and so
that's when the majority tips and so I
think there's gonna be a point for a
couple years you know maybe 10 20 years
where people are hearing about it you
know it's something in the zeitgeist
just like the iPhone was in the
site-geist it's like oh people are
living in these code living communities
people are living you know in these
smaller cellular communities and having
these great experiences and you're
seeing this there's some I think there's
one called the collective in London
that's making these communal houses like
they're actually buying the real estate
and like people are moving into them but
it has they don't have the full
community integration that were going
for but the idea is that this is it's
brimming right but it's still kind of an
educator
and so I think when it gets to the idea
that when you're leaving college the
idea that you would live in a little
apartment on your own becomes weird
becomes the lagging and the idea that
you move into a community an
intergenerational lively vibrant
community right out of college or during
college right which you have which you
have kind of in the dorms so probably
after college becomes much more viable
and then a lot of people are going to be
start adopting that word light homes
college or school you lived there before
you go to college you lived after school
to that it's that kind of a place where
right you're getting a very valuable and
it's slow it's very incremental it's
very slow yes yeah yeah the hippie thing
was a revolution right it's I think a
lot of people draw parallels between
this idea and and the 70s and they say
oh so you're gonna you know run off into
the woods and make a commune
that's not what we're doing right I
think that's too drastic all right I'm
gonna call me yeah all right my counter
is that one of the best code deployments
is potentially the pantheon right we
have to we have to actually do this at
at these at the scale and deploy and see
what what what is actually occurring
from this it sounds fantastic and I
think in many ways that is kind of like
what we have here in the studio or what
we have in these apartment complexes
already but just obviously on mother
earth instead with sunlight instead with
completely closed loop feedback yellow
systems yep and and one-on-one
mentorship teaching children to give
them nutrients I mean it's so okay so
that's great let's deploy that let's
test our counter I think is I think it
may be easier
to deploy a meme of some sort
that is very profound in shifting one's
perspective to a communion with all that
is I have a strong feeling that what I'm
currently synthesizing all these jigsaw
pieces all that is is code the seeds
need the nutrients a hundred billion
people built civilization before us
there's the edge of knowledge keep
pushing out past the edge of knowledge
bring it down in relatable ways to the
seeds that are being birthed you only
get thirty thousand days to live a third
of them you're gonna spend sleeping
suspend your twenty thousand days
actualizing yourself it's your fullest
right I've so many of these jigsaw
pieces now that I'm trying to synthesize
and work with other brilliant minds to
play this tennis game with to make this
puzzle stronger and deploy this code and
I think that a Meem deployed from that
puzzle as a pen be a single image and I
can give you an example of a single
image that I think this is a good one I
think that if you take a image of what
looks like indigenous people kind of
hanging out in like a little rain forest
area and they're you know maybe you have
a fire and have some of the instruments
that they're playing with and then right
next to the indigenous people you have a
white person from the United States and
an Asian person let's say from China and
they're both sitting there on their
laptops coding and they're like will you
keep it down please we're trying to code
a GI you know or something like that
right that's in this little image right
so I think that with maybe an image like
that or with thirty second video about
this puzzle or
or 60-second video about this puzzle or
a 20 minute short film or a 16 minute
longer film or TV series however you
want to do it right I think that with
memes you can get people to break out of
their habits of using the old code that
is that is bad and causing loved ones
and potentially getting them to
understand this big history perspective
get them to understand the communion
with all that is get them to understand
that they want to be a part of this
conversation with civilization about
what new code to run that will maximize
the human experiment so I think I think
that's that's such a such an interesting
point and I think the the thing I'll add
on to that or like kind of the the way
I'll push back against that is lifespan
and what I mean by that is if you
imagine the code as a water so it's like
a huge rushing river the code that is
very solidified in there you can imagine
it's ice right it's stuck in there and
there's their stuff that's going by all
the time but the ice is the stuff that's
that's really being run on a daily basis
so what I mean is the ice is the built
environment right we were talking in the
last episode about how the built
environment is very static technology is
incredibly fast media as part of
Technology right does this video is part
of the media of technology it's growing
very fast this video you know we're
creating it on the fly and people can
see thousands of these videos you know a
day and then culture is in the middle
and culture is where we live right so I
think the problem is is that by playing
on the time scale like a meme is on the
timescale of Technology a meme is
incredibly fast right you can see that
image that you just talked about in two
seconds during your day and maybe it has
a profound impact on you on that day and
maybe seeing 20 of them has a profound
impact on you and maybe seeing 2,000 of
them has an incredibly profound impact
on you and you actually start changing
your behaviors right but I think the
fundamental problem with that is is that
its lifespan is too short and what I
mean by that is we're hit by so much
information at every time that a meme
can get lost in the noise what cannot
get lost in the noise is this
this is real right I can close my eyes
that's still there a meme isn't there
when I close my eyes right when I walk
into a room the way the environment is
built shapes my behavior subconsciously
I can't even fight it right a meme I
cannot look at it check out that episode
with with evan bliss that we just
published on ethos of architecture he
acts on that exactly exactly right and
so I think if your solution is through
technology it will it will be lost in
the noise and maybe some people will get
or not that's that's good likes I like
this point this is a very very good
right point so then how do you shape the
mimetics
to not get lost in the noise physically
oh and that's what the Pantheon is is
it's the physical communiques and that
way it doesn't move it doesn't move and
that way you every single day you're in
a community what are the five again let
me what are the five autonomy gratitudes
last one is yes
mentorships not in there it's it's it's
one of the words it's and it's not one
of the words it's in the system that
like though these are the fundamental
things and mentorship is how you
implement it but okay okay community
belonging but wonky wonky belonging
belongings at the end right but
gratitude and gratitude autonomy what
was it like values or no math mastery Oh
mastery that nice Tantra crucial life
and and purpose and perfect donna me
purpose masteries what's acronym is
there an acronym it's it's amp BG it's a
pretty chair that's fine amp and VG
helps its lot yeah watch amp BG yeah amp
BG okay candle out of the watch amp BG
okay autonomy mastery purpose belonging
gratitude ant BG helps but I also just
heard it recently from you but still if
now that I have an acronym for it I
promise I'll be able to recall it
because that's very important now the
reason why you bring up a physical space
being so crucial yeah you see you you're
immersed in that every single day I
can't sit yeah I want to I want to also
do another push back because I don't I
don't I don't know if maybe maybe means
a ton autonomy mastery purpose gratitude
and and and belonging and I think I
think that mastery within a context of
meditation or of psychedelics or of some
sort of incorporation of a meme like
what if it's an ongoing TV series that
becomes part of culture that it becomes
the ice so you know so here so here okay
so here's the idea is that is that I
think we we got into this stuff through
the memes and what I mean by that and I
think
it's it's important to clarify when
we're saying memes we don't mean Pepe
the Frog we don't mean you know mimetics
the cultural dissemination of
information yeah the the what the word
meme meant before 2020 2010 right the
original mean the so I think we got
interested in what we're interested in
through books which are memes I threw
through maybe television series maybe
through other talks we've heard online
TED Talks TED talks are memes but
through listening to the smartest people
in the world deliver messages right yes
and those just like where Ron was saying
in the last episode he said like you
know he said does he said hey keep
dreaming kid but that's not the way the
world works
and that's because the physical nature
of the world is not in line with this
stuff and so that's the problem that
we're having is we're talking about all
these fancy ideas in the intellectual
sphere but it's not being implemented in
stone right it's not being implemented
in this week's a lot also interestingly
enough to your I think to your iranian
your persian roots i think i think and i
think it potentially helps me better
understand with some of the armenian
roots that i have as well absolutely
that I get what you're saying more
because that you came here with your mom
and dad's parents so that's another
interesting thing is that there was no
like you know it's just you know we're
moving to the US it's like no or Bri you
know but and most people don't sometimes
have though you know the ability to do
so but this is such an interesting point
is that routing routing a new physical
system is it's almost like potentially a
somehow stronger ice maybe that
permafrost right is what you're trying
to do physical yeah digital might only
be the the the thin stuff that can get
broken when the when something really
fast something else comes out so and and
this is so I'm gonna do a couple
different zooms but but but so what you
were saying initially you know with the
code as being the Sun as a certain
distance from the earth and the human
heart be beats a certain amount
that is maybe the most intense
permafrost if you think about it okay
that's good because it's really really
hard to change those things it's really
really hard to chuck the earth out of
orbit or something like that and in
comparison to the Sun so I think that's
actually code that that's gonna run
every time especially because it's
physical its biological its chemical
right it's happening at a chemical level
at a biological level that's why your
heart's beating the way it does the way
that society is running is at the most
free and lucid level of the code that
stuff's gonna be deleted and changed all
the time days code these code not being
tucked around we're talking about how
like a message being sent from one
person to another person is is code is
the newest absolute newest code and some
of the oldest code is that our heart
beats a hundred thousand grams or that
son is thank you yeah and so I can say
to you right now you know that plant is
pink it's not right like because I say
it doesn't make it true if I took a
spray can and changed and and
spray-painted that thing that would be a
more solid and and rigid and immovable
aspect I just added to the code base
that would be closer to ice because you
would actually have to wipe it off or
something to change it back and show me
saying so this is that's pretty
potentially closer to a permafrost is
truth yeah yeah like falsifiable truth
is closer to permafrost because if I say
you know this is pink
you're like clearly it's not but you
imagined it for a second to do I think
so weed existed for a second and the
code base and now it's gone if I painted
it pink it would really be paying tall
you cut it off or scraped it off exactly
yeah and so the idea is that the built
environment is the stuff that stays and
the built environment is what influences
the culture Khurram at a huge level and
so the problem isn't that technology is
going off on this curve
it's that technology's going off on this
curve and that the built environment is
staying the same and it's breaking
culture in the middle what we need to do
is update the built environment so that
it's so that it so that the culture
exists in it better and we also need a
rain back some of the technological
stuff because it's it's going too far in
that direction
that this the permafrost you know can't
it can be updated and then oh break
again when technology keeps going and
they'll be updating and breaking it with
technology keep going what we need to do
is we need to create a dynamic system a
closed loop in which technology is going
at the same speed as the built
environment it's going at the same speed
as culture and and then it can actually
sustain because if you look at like the
earth right the earth is a closed is a
closed loop culture needs to be
advancing as quickly as the built
environments advancing as quickly as the
digital technological invite and
actually I would say not as quickly as
the technology stuff I think it needs to
speed up a little bit but I think
technology needs to slow down a lot I
think technology also needs to slow down
a bit I think that we've done several
conversations on the channel about we're
not ready for transhumanism we're not
we haven't will never be volved well I
think we'll know and we're trapped in
the biological permafrost right we're
trapped in these bodies and I think that
makes it so that we'll always have a
rationality we'll always have a little
bit of tribalism we'll always have a
little bit essentially ways around that
though there are potentially ways around
that there's there's all different types
of simulations virtual realities brain
computer interfaces digitizing
consciousnesses there's so many which
are quite far away I would say for some
of those things but it's still a
interesting thought experiment that can
get your tritiated sumit ism but we are
not really good but you brought up a
very very interesting point which is
that built environment needs to pick
pick itself up which is through things
like the Pantheon through things like
right and dynamically rearranged herbal
environments I think are super important
slows down potentially slowing down
it's not like saying like don't keep
bringing down the genetics lancing right
right Carlson curve it's not saying that
down it's not saying that it's saying
you know keep bringing that down but
really have a geopolitical consensus yes
fact that you're now going to have
synthetic biology tools in the hands of
the most malevolent actors yeah it's not
it's not saying stop making vaccines
it's not saying stop doing scientific
research it's saying stop making dog
food delivery
services right it's saying stop doing
the crap we don't need because when you
have the built environment and culture
being in harmony when you have the right
values in society then the technology
can now be in service of that now
technology can enter the the arena
because what we're happening right now
as I said in the last episode and I
think a lot of those only make sense of
yours a lot of it but that technology is
framing the rest of the stuff and that's
bad we're basing our culture and we're
basing our built environment we're not
basing our limit we're basing our
culture based on technology but they're
not in harmony what needs to happen is
is technology needs to be reacting to
the needs of the culture it needs to be
reacting to the needs of the built
environment not going off on its own
route for the sake of money yeah for the
sake of money and for the sake of power
and for the sake of these things which
is what it's doing right now it needs to
come back to be in service of the human
to be in service of the goals that we
have established so instead of being in
the service of money which it's doing
right now there are a lot of services
out there that don't really do anything
for anyone but make someone so stupid
rich right there's stuff that's in
service of increasing people's comfort
unnecessarily and there's stuff that
since in that increases people's status
right people make a shitty startup so
they can get clout right what is that
the technology shouldn't be used to
boost people in a way that doesn't even
fulfill them right technology should be
in service of the people and it's in
service of the people if it's increasing
our autonomy if it's increasing our
purpose and and those things and if it's
helping our basic needs the VAX so the
MGP sits on top of basic needs right so
if the technology is helping us get more
autonomy purpose mastery gratitude all
that stuff fantastic and if it's
servicing our basic needs which is
health and those things access to clean
water that is the technology we need to
be ok it's not saying yes to it when
we're slowing down technology what we
mean by that is not stopping the
research labs right it's making more
research labs to focus on those things
it's putting more people on the basic
need and the less people and on like
yeah you know like
betting on who's gonna win the next
sports game over some I mean like none
of that stuff actually helps us write
the stuff that really helps us is is
fulfilling our basic needs and
fulfilling these other things autonomy
mastery purpose belonging gratitude yeah
and so so the idea is that we need to be
working at all these scales so you were
saying the memes right you were saying
what if I'm this show right where does
this show fit in to the process and and
and I here's what I think it does I
think David Eagleman great mentor mine
was on the show yeah shout out David
much much incredible incredible
incredible guy talks about in his talk
at the Aspen Institute and in this book
the runaway species he talks about
creativity and how there are ideas that
that are doing slight changes to the
status quo and their ideas that are
trying to completely reform the entire
status chlorite right and that a
successful person has multiple ideas
that are working at these different
scales and usually in service of each
other so the things happening at the
small scale is actually in service of
the larger goal and that's the idea
behind the Pantheon is we have three
horizons horizon one being projects that
we can do today we can literally do
today that that move the needle a little
bit and that generate resources for us
to do stuff tomorrow horizon 2 is takes
a little bit more work a little bit more
effort moving the needle a lot more but
it's harder to do and requires more
research and horizon 3 stuff which is
like a society scale super hard to do
changing like built environment
infrastructure stuff and so I think we
need to have things at all these
different time scales I think this show
and the memes as you're talking about
them are in the horizon one time scale
which is that we were doing them today
we're having this conversation today
we're getting these ideas out there
today and horizon through time skills
building the built environment yeah
and horizon 3 times like time or I guess
the full like whole world in the built
environment would be like
horizon 3 thinkers us doing our own
little community is like somewhere
between horizon 1 and 2 it's like it
takes effort and takes research and it
takes trying out to do but we can kind
of do it today but the idea is that that
alone doesn't tip the needle super hard
it's when we create a when we really
test that in horizon 2 and we really get
a great model of it that we can export
it to being a horizon 3 thing where
everyone can now get on board I mean
you're trying to move these ideas ideas
from horizon 3 closer to horizon 1 all
the time right yeah yeah another way to
think about that is that you we're
constantly evolving the ethics of the
species yeah trying to push push us
closer to the progress yeah and that you
want to move the Overton Window right of
acceptable ideas wide open on that side
and close it off on this side cuz the
malevolent code exactly nevolin code and
the benevolent code requires the memes
in this sort of phase exactly requires
the built physical environment to really
start to move us really start the app in
that dress and then once we get you know
you could you know we're trying to move
the needle to get to this new aunt BG
basic needs met world right this this
world like in the Pantheon model but
then when that has kind of become the
norm when that's easy to do when that's
accepted when that's in horizon one you
know we're gonna realize there's
problems that we couldn't even think
about until that was solved right and
now they're gonna be new problems in
horizon 3 and we're gonna start needing
to to normalize those and horizon one
through talking about them right
intellectualizing about them we're gonna
need to start getting them into the
culture cuz because that's how that's
what this this talk is doing right now
we're talking about these things at a
very high level over time these things
your boys about to continue
disseminating them to everybody else
that he talks to exams they'll keep
talking other till tee-time it'll become
part of the overall culture the ideas
will get into movies go get into TV
shows they'll get into the normal things
and then those things will start to get
reinforced by the the physical stuff we
start to do ha so it does start with the
it does you ha it does it does right you
have to have stuff at every scale stuff
at every scale for that is part of the
creative genius so this is this is as
much a part of the the process as is
building the physical environment we
need to get you on to talk about the
actual code of the panel events I loved
it yeah I looked at that we can talk
about that yeah yeah tell us about this
because you know we're now we're
propagating this idea of we want the
memes to spread about about you know
about spiritual actualization and about
getting every seat the right nutrients
and again at about about just about
updating code since code to be better
and having these profound awakening
things but we also simultaneously want
to be rooted in these physical
environments that foster autonomy
mastery purpose belonging gratitude so
and of the basic needs met and all of
the basic easements so now how does the
design and we need visuals for this
beside of white board will go without
visuals I mean okay we do have a white
board but well you know I can get behind
the robos and do some stuff but well
will will will have more visuals for
this another yeah time soon
yeah ohm and I are gonna try to make I
love this for this elevator you guys
from our presentation background we're
gonna try exactly you and own can both
come on with visuals and we can really
yeah I'd love to it I'd really give us
no abstract right okay so the abstract
idea right now which has been existing
in my head when I'm saying this stuff so
it may seem like I'm over selling this
idea that I only briefly mentioned but
it's it's in there so so the idea here
is that the the basic building block of
it the most fundamental permafrost you
will of it is the actual physical
community so you have a complex of
buildings it can be one building the
idea is that it can be modular and it
can be adaptive so if you're in a if
a conservative Muslim community and they
need separation between different
chambers of the house you can you can
have that evident in the architecture if
you're in a community where you know
they don't want it to be super co-ed or
whatever you can change the architecture
of the house to look like that the
architecture of the community of 150
people if you want it to be a super you
know open inclusive already you have
questions what happens when someone
wants a bigger room is someone else that
that's that stuff that gets worked out
within the 150 of the communities the
idea is that we don't put legislature on
top of that because you know if you want
a bigger place you can either talk to
the other people about getting parts of
their spaces or you can try and move to
different hundred 50 community where you
people have more space yeah the the idea
is that where people have more space in
general in general or they they're
willing to give more space because they
don't care the location this is very
libertarian area with with the code that
is law in though each of the 150 pocket
yeah so the reason why we don't have
like top-down legislature is because
it's actually really easy to work out
you you actually don't need a police
force in a group of 150 people the
interpersonal connections between those
150 people actually serve as enough as a
social glue and if you're living with
those people you don't want to piss
those people off so you don't like do
stupid things around them like I'm
thinking about my dorm at college I'm
not gonna go into someone else's room
that I know that I see every day even
though their doors unlock I'm not gonna
go in and take their stuff when I easily
could because I'm gonna be living next
to that person for the rest I think it's
not even a thought that crosses my mind
yeah but you're at summer camp with
someone for a week you're never seen
you're gonna see this person again how
many kids you know steal something
probably a lot more than in college
right where you have this strong
interpersonal connection so the idea is
that in groups of 150 people
interpersonal conflicts can get resolved
without the without needing a third
party mediator which means that actually
both parties are happier because they
came to the conclusion themselves as
opposed to some judge saying yes or no
and then them having to kind of deal
with the ramifications and it's usually
kind of skewed one way so interest so
that's get self-regulate their
governance and we're actually good at
this like we've forgotten this in the
past two hundred years when we've been
living in our nuclear families and
living in isolation but humans have been
living in communities of 150 people
since Homo erectus like we've been doing
this forever for 200,000 years Homo
erectus was around for three million
years we know how to do this the reason
why we can read each other's facial
expressions the reason why we have all
these weirdly accessible comes millions
of years to do it and and and we're
relying on the the fundamentals to
structure us are real eyebrows and eyes
and right as opposed to legal codes
which don't actually exist which which
are stuff that people made up as opposed
to the interpersonal stuff that really
exists I mean right here we're relying
on that to be to be our code right and
that's a stronger more permafrost code
then and then the like ice water that's
flop interesting so I actually did not
think that you were gonna tell us that a
hundred and fifty people have a strong
ability to do self-regulate self-govern
do that's a very cool start okay so they
I still I'm still very confused about
kind of like how people will jump into
like these different like I want more
space I want less space well I want to I
want to nudity do be okay you know it's
like there's all these different if we
did Burning Man camp yeah it's a very
it's a very similar thing and those
actually run really well and I think
Bernie has a lot of which we went to for
your first I did I went last year and
I'll be going again hopefully with some
people who were born in nineteen
straight years like junior the okay so
so and that's kind of going into the
weeds of it a bit which we have thought
about so I can go into the weeds of we
need to go into being okay
the smallest unit of measurement in this
society is the hundred fifty people the
the point I was making with that you can
organize it different ways is that the
physical environment of that may not
always be one house you know for some
people there'll be one house for some
people will be a collection of houses
around the nucleus right first it's
going to look different
but it's always gonna be maximum 150
people some of them will be less some of
them will be a little more hopefully the
average is 150 that's the basic building
block of the society is this if this
group of Andra so literally the Dunbar
number is like the first code line of
code because because it's permafrost
because it's just like it's just like
you know how your heart beats a hundred
thousand times a day it's a hundred
thousand times a day and just like the
Sun is a certain distance from the earth
90 million miles those are my numbers
yeah those are your numbers my numbers
and I am and your number is 150 people
mpg yeah 150 people is I think as true
as those things that is as true as you
know the number of electrons around a
certain atom it's a fundamental axiom of
the human mind that we have a hundred
space for a hundred fifty people give or
take you know fifty basically 365 point
two five is another interesting one
doing this just for the days in the year
yeah around orbit the star yeah exactly
and so it's the same it's the same thing
so that's our that's our smallest unit
of measurement is 150 people and then
you have those you can call those atoms
those atoms are surrounded by other
atoms that make up their local molecule
those local molecules are surrounded by
other local molecules that make up their
local cell those cells then coal
coalesce I was using coalesce always
mess up the word with collate coalesce
to make the organ to organism which is
our overall Society yeah and that's
what's great about it is that can be
cross planetary right you can have atoms
on the moon and atoms on the earth that
are part of the same organism they're
not part of the same molecule but
they're part of the same organism and
they can be running similar code right
that's adapted for their unique
environments because on the moon maybe
you need a couple different things going
on in the structure of the atoms and
stuff like that you need a you know have
things you don't have on earth like a
vac
you know like oxygen chambers and stuff
like that which changed the way the
structure looks but it's the same
fundamental framework just like if you
were to take humans today this reminds
me a lot of The Venus Project in terms
of just a pure insanity
yes very green very technical ethical
yes that that very sustainable very
interconnected yeah and that that that's
a little bit of like a visual vision
that right as feeling and so the idea
being that just like if we went to the
moon today people would think of you
know and or colonizing Mars or whatever
people would think of building houses
like the suburbs we have today that's
the code that we're running that isn't
working right yeah because the only two
really options are metropolis is which
is the or suburban I know and we're
saying no it's we're doing organic
volcanic Nicholas they don't work at all
so you don't they don't no they don't
you're either isolating people or
crowding people and making them
anonymous both of our terrible ideas
this is the correct model I think which
is based on the Dunbar number which is a
axiom right but then you do go hang out
I mean you could spend all of your time
going to another cell yes if you go to
another cell that has their own 150
Dunbar number there's it what if you
stay over at someone's house there you
can you can like I I mean my dorm but
then I guess is sort of a like
responsibility in your cell like what
you do know you do and then if you don't
do what if you don't you know do the
responsibility that you're supposed to
do in the cell
no cops gonna come after you your aunt
is gonna come after you your mentor is
gonna come after you and say where were
you you know it's people you know oh so
that's the dumb part remember exactly
you're not gonna because in the stranger
don't give a round you'll leave yeah in
my dorm even which is kind of strange
because we know we're only gonna be
there a year you know sometimes people
leave a little bit of stuff out in the
kitchenette but they get railed for it
still right like people will text in the
group me you know I know you didn't
clean up after yourself in the kitchen
and don't go back and do it because
they're living side to side with the
person that just called them out yeah
right if you're living in an anonymous
community you don't give a crap if you
put a litter on the floor that's why
people are okay with
in cities because they don't feel like
the city as their community that's why
they're okay tagging the walls because
they don't they don't care right because
no one's gonna come after them the
person who's gonna come after them as
the cops they don't care what the cop
thinks right you care what your mom
thinks you care what your aunt thinks
you care what the lady - raised you
Thanks who isn't your mom you care what
you're like you know you're essentially
your non-biological cousin think's right
when you knock something over on your
living room floor and everyone shares
and you don't clean it you're gonna get
rekt by your immediate community of 150
people so the idea is that you're
relying on the systems that work which
are interpersonal connection as opposed
to systems that don't work which are
authoritative and impersonal anonymous
enforcement that doesn't work what does
work is your mom's always gonna love you
the woman that raised you with a man
that raised you or whoever raised you is
always gonna love you even if they're
not your parents and even if you do some
stupid thing like you know cut up
decoration on the wall or spill
something you know they're not gonna go
put you in jail they're gonna foster you
and nurture you which is how we know
which is the way to rehabilitate people
and you don't need a trained
psychiatrists you don't need a trained
psychologists of how to rehabilitate
condit or how to rehabilitate these
people the you do it naturally as a
human being because that's how we're
built right so that's the that's the
fundamental idea behind the hundred
fifty people so you have this community
of hundred people you have this atomic
system right based on the atoms and the
cells and all this stuff and then within
the atom what does life look like within
the atom we have a couple different
aspects of it you have the community
life you have working life like
productive life and then you have you
have education and the three are stacked
on top of each other so Andrew Carnegie
famously said incorrectly that the first
third of your life should be focused on
gaining as much education as you can the
second half second third should be get
getting as much money as you can and the
last or getting as much resources as you
can and the last last should be giving
it all the way the last search became
you know what we're doing is we take
education reactionary methods of that
second part are disastrous and they're
terrible right so that that ones I mean
that one's horrible not even mentioning
how horrible the segmented approaches
and the fact that it yeah education
doesn't go throughout life exactly
so we stretch education out through all
life we stretch out community all
throughout life and work all throughout
life the Japanese don't have a word that
means retire because the idea of
fundamentally stopping doing stuff
doesn't make any sense for them for your
brain in it catalyzes Alzheimer's we
think it does yep the idea of retirement
is a bad idea
so so so here's what that looks like you
have these mentorship change based on
the Aristotle Plato Socrates model when
it when a child is born of course
they're born into a family and there are
immediate people around them that are
not their parents that are also helping
to raise them but I think and we have to
do research on what the right ages but I
think when they're around seven or eight
they are assigned to a mentorship chain
so that means they're assigned a mentor
that's probably like 15 I think it that
we earlier okay so so so and that's why
I'm saying we need to test the numbers
on this so maybe it's from their birth
yeah that's from their elderly and they
have a they have someone who's three
years old and the new six years that are
really good at looking at children there
right away born and being like look at
what where they're going looking right
they're gravitating towards exactly what
to help you know put yeah yeah and doing
like much better and earlier and
ubiquitous testing of different
cognitive abilities so for example I
know because I've done learning profile
testing that I have like really high
auditory memory but really terrible
working memory and things like that so
if we could understand those things and
kids earlier you could assign them to
the right mentorship chain to basically
say okay this is a group of people that
that talks a lot so this kid is gonna be
do very well with them because he has a
high auditory memory he's being able to
learn much better from them than a group
of people that are much more about
drawing out their ideas and stuff like
that which would be much better for a
visual learner so you can that's part of
the way that you can assign people to
these to these mentorship change but
you're you essentially a you
them in in this lineage we're the oldest
person is is the oldest person in the
society basically or one of the oldest
people in that atom cell so they call
that it yeah you call that an atom in
the hundred fifty okay and okay so so
you'd probably be getting we don't work
out the numbers I'm an atom is an
individual and atoms 150 people and a
person is in the atom 150 people to an
atom to an atom yeah and lame than atoms
mica molecules yeah and those cells
themselves and you can make as many
delineation sure of that as you want
point being you know you shut that
humans be that atoms and then they make
up 150 make up a molecule sure sure just
cuz you know I'm using the atom Azzam as
a model we could think of different
names that are more meaningful this has
been very good breakdown yeah yeah so
this is how the education system works
is you have that that mentorship chain
so this kid has a mentor that's a couple
years old them to a couple years old
he's Plato Aristotle Socrates Plato
Aristotle great oh it's great it's a
great but yeah so it's based on that
model of stacking knowledge stacking
knowledge docking knowledge oh and blue
to Sigma and bloom to sit together it is
like just huge huge right so if every
kid had this even if their mentor that's
a couple years old of them is kind of
bad and even if their mentor that 30
years all of them is kind of bad there's
gonna be one or two in the chain of like
20 people that are in their mentors
obtain that are gonna give them
something useful and care about them
what is the role of robotics and
artificial intelligence in these in
these areas I mean dizzy
every cell gets to pick the role that it
has you know who's the first person to
pick you know whether there are
refrigerators you know how does the
hundred fifty people pick whether they
want to eat gross spinach or carrots or
will drones just be flying in whatever
people
to order I think I think a lot of it
will be self-sustaining in the community
so a lot of the stuff will be made
within the community itself and so part
of that is doing like new innovations in
agriculture so this is this is what
we're talking about slowing down
technology and kind of refocusing it to
the right things so if we actually
refocus technology on better like
sustainable agriculture stuff and on
like making maker spaces better yeah
this would help a lot so what you do is
you have within the atom you have
basically food that can sustain that
atom and not necessarily much more
because you don't want puppy huge
population growth right you have food
that's being grown
maybe vertical gardens maybe hydroponics
healthy sustainable good food that's
being grown locally right next to them
doesn't need to be imported or flown in
right there and then the community cooks
it and distributes it to their to their
people and then you have advanced maker
spaces based on the model of Brett
Victor and we can put links to this
stuff in the bottom he calls them seeing
spaces right Victor to see if imagism he
he does they're part of a keynote
address so it would in order to find it
be harder to find the the idea being
that when you have these these maker
spaces that are highly assisted meaning
a kid can walk in and basically say oh I
need to make a new coat and the
environment kind of rearranges around
them to be like alright you need to cut
out templates and do this stuff it helps
them do that so a lot of this stuff is
kind of going back to this model of of
making it yourself and and whatnot and
the food being grown yourself and self
sustainability within the atom and so
you don't need the trade economy as much
okay so you don't be there would be some
sort of a trade economy there would be
some sort of not I was gonna make
computers or not every cells gonna me
right and probably no cells will be
making computers the computers will
probably be made by the like by
mechanized like AI stuff outside of this
whyn't food because that's more human
because the food is something that the
people in the community actually need
it's like a basic need thing and like
the maker space allows them to create
other basic needs thing like like
clothing and repairs and stuff like that
and like Owen Joy's makerspace like a
community space to solve the basic need
yeah yeah so those are kind of the
building blocks is like is like the like
the agriculture innovations and then the
makerspace innovations like supply the
basic needs of the community and of
course like water purification you know
all that stuff and kind of the the stuff
that isn't within that category I think
number one the demand for that stuff on
a global scale will go down because you
realize you don't need a lot of it oh
that's this decrease in consumerism
which is interesting right yeah and if
and if you do need something you can
have a Burning Man will feel about like
they're you know degrees of freedom
being cut to not be able to buy boats or
yachts or whatever or chats so those are
things we're gonna have to work out you
know like this is I think a lifetime
thinking thing you know a lot of these
ideas of spiritual evolution Rueda yeah
but with that damn this is okay yeah
this is this is too this is too awesome
and yeah and loaded with this is a lot
here a lot too yeah this is a lot to
unpack it is it is very cool though I
think you know some some very
interesting takeaways we started talking
about all that is being code and then we
talked about how to augment that code
and then we talked about certain
malevolence Azure benevolences being
programmed
the code and then we got to you know
mimetics being able to be something that
can help spread around the ideas in very
profound ways and then the we have to
change the built physical environment
that we reside in and that if that built
if that physical environment is built
with basic needs and autonomy mastery
purpose belonging and gratitude that
that is pretty good great code along
with like a Dunbar number that that
there's a sense of the self regulation
and self-governance I can come from that
and that that can be our built
environment way to to make the code
better so this is kind of our little
full so full circle yeah and it's also
funny that we ended up actually you know
talking about a lot of this episode 345
yeah we're getting in to afford this
yeah and this was this was super super
enlightening and fun and absolutely yeah
I'm glad that we did this I'm glad that
we kind of like decided that let's have
you ask me stuff and then it ended up
being playing tennis to figure out the
code yeah then we figured out that you
know a lot of the code is the you know
the pinyon and and that's why I think we
also gravitate towards one another
absolutely and the dialogue model as
being right going back to what we were
talking about Socrates to Plato there's
all right yes the dialogue has invented
by Plato and Socrates the Plato using
the only the only way we even know about
Socrates is through the writings of
Plato where he's a character in the
dialogue you know so I I'm in a program
at Stanford called Slee which is
structured liberal education where we've
been reading a lot of these texts and
before coming to sleet always thought
Socrates was a was a dude we had
writings from all right yeah and what
you realize or what I was I learned when
I was there is that we know about
Socrates through the writings mainly a
Plato a little bit from
one of his other students but mainly
through Plato and and not just Plato
writing about Socrates as this and that
but Plato writing a dialogue in which
Socrates is a character conversing with
other interlocutors and kind of
developing his ideas and that as being
the building block that led to this
amazing chain of people from Socrates to
Plato to air assault Alexander the Great
who were able to create so much that our
world is based on now is through the
dialogue model is through the model of
of conversation and working out ideas
together yes right because I could have
come in here and I you know or you could
have asked me just write it out and we
could have worked but it wouldn't it
wouldn't have resonated with me it
wouldn't have resonated with you
it wouldn't show how we arrived at those
ideas is how we played the tennis match
and this is what we got as some of the
cool hits back exactly that got us to
where we are this
it's kind of what decart we've done with
the first principles right like our
first principles are the code that the
hardest of the permafrost right the
first principles are you know how many
times your heart is beating yeah and how
frost was a very important thing
yeah member is long and then we were
able to build on top of that and say
okay how do we improve that how do we
improve that after we established the
core and I think if you watch this
conversation even when we look back on
this conversation can see how we arrived
at certain ideas and was like we were
pulling these numbers you know out of
thin air it's you know correct we're
pulling this stuff out of out of the way
the conversation is going and by
stacking kind of the permafrost or the
first principles don't yeah on top of
each other top of each other yeah whoa
this is been super fun re I'm just I'm
like I'm you know lit up with with you
know with your with your beautiful 19
year old creative vision like I love it
and I love I love thinking about how to
you know bring this forth into into the
world and it starts with this you know
this this
these memes and the other permafrost
under new deployments and code
thank you again they feels really great
so technically that was like what you
have three straight hours of law on
verse a ssin with that break of whatever
thirty minutes in between the two one
and a half hour segments but cool that
was episode this was episode 346 go
check out 3:45 the first episode in the
conversation with re and then this one
as well thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly greatly appreciate it much much
love to you we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below please
please please let us know your thoughts
and comments below get talking to other
people about what we talked about and
more and huge shout out to Alan Alan
Saucon our our producer and director or
the show yeah and go and build everyone
go and manifest your dreams in the world
check out our ease links below check out
simulations links below support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in build the future manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much everyone and we will see you
soon peace